[Music]
let's go to oklahoma city and talk to
isaac what's up isaac how we doing
hey john hey george i'm doing good how
are you guys outstanding brother what's
up
okay so i bought my first house i moved
from california to oklahoma uh i'm
feeling like i bought a bought a little
more than i can chew so i need some help
on understanding that and then am i
doing the right stuff with my finances
like budget and whatnot
okay more than you can chew like too
many half too many rooms to vacuum or
whether you can chew it you bought way
too much house you know what it's like
that's why it's too expensive too much
money okay what's your take-home pay
yeah
monthly it's about 2186.
something about 40k a year
okay what is this mortgage payment with
the property insurance taxes interest
all that
uh so it's 1100. oh my god whoa
yeah
over 50 percent of your take-home pay is
going so that you can live in this box
yeah ouch how many bedrooms is it is it
just you
uh no i saw mary 25 married and i got
three boys
okay is your wife working inside the
home or she home with the kids
we've literally been talking about just
got off the phone with her they're
opening up a store here so she's home
right now but we're thinking about her
getting a part-time job or doing some
door dash during the day
yeah i think i'm working it's the only
option right now if you want to stay in
this house how soon can you get your
income up what do you do for a living
so i do insurance
uh so i do like account managing so i
make
the commission or salary
salary based
but is there commission on top of that
very small yeah so if i do like personal
insurance so if i sell a policy i get 10
of the 12 that the agency gets is this
what you were put on earth to do
was this just a job you stumbled into
and you had when you had your first kid
then you've kind of been doing this
i just been working i started working at
15 at raley's and then just kept going
and
work his work do you have a degree just
trying to
nothing no college high school diploma
okay is this a 30-year mortgage
yeah oh okay
so here's the deal you've heard both of
me and george go we've exhaled a few
times with you
um we're gonna get all that out of our
system and now it's gonna be in solution
mode are you ready for that
okay let's do it okay you're so you're
all in
i'm all in okay how much does this house
cost by the way
uh 195. okay
how much did you put down
uh about
percentage-wise yeah
i think three to five percent
okay
and how long ago did you
buy it
january
okay so it's been about eight months now
oh boy
i mean are you guys able to breathe like
can you put food on the table
well we've been making it thus far we've
got a
tight pretty tight budget
i just calculated our last month budget
and we were about a thousand dollars
over
um
what does rent cost in your area for you
know i'm guessing you need at least
three bedroom
yeah
so it's about
similar to the mortgage um
so depending on where i mean i live in a
decent neighborhood not you know the
nicest parts obviously
um and so
it's about the same it's not much
cheaper or more expensive how old are
these boys
i got a seven-year-old a two-year-old
and a one-month-old
okay so even if
but if you sold this thing you would
you'd have still very little money you
don't have much equity in this thing at
all
no i i think there's
like 10 grand equity or something like
that so this it doesn't solve many
problems to sell it and go rent
somewhere for the same amount
no so the only other option i'm seeing
is we have to double your income like
tomorrow
and that might mean a new career field
doing something different in sales
working for another agency that's
commission based and you go crush it you
kill it and drag it home so you can put
food on the table and afford your
mortgage
okay
or it may also mean and this is going to
be tough
um i was hoping you're gonna tell me
your boys were nine and seven and six so
they could go to school when your wife
gets a full-time job
um but you've got two
under three right you got two two and
younger that's gonna be so you're gonna
you're gonna be out another 600 bucks
she's gonna have to go get a job
regardless okay
um well let me george stop me if i get
out of my head here so i'm trying to put
myself in his situation
and
if i'm honest with you man i can hear it
on you
like you found yourself stressed yeah
exactly
i need you to let the shame part of this
go
okay
you're doing what you were told to do
which is to get in line for all these
different products and things and just
go figure it out and we'll just get a
mortgage and let's get a house and let's
leave california all those things you
just did what you were told and here's
where you find yourself okay you're not
a crappy dad and you're not a screw-up
and you're not a loser is that cool
hard to believe
i know i'll go with it i know i can hear
it on you but if you continue to drag
that around with you it will hold you
back from getting a promotion it's going
to hold you back from going back to
school it's going to hold you back from
all the stuff and most importantly it's
going to hold you back from being
connected with your wife you're going to
need her arm and arm on this one as
y'all move forward is that cool yeah
okay so we're we're done with the head
down we're gonna pick our head up and
say cool we found ourselves in a big big
hole and we're moving forward and by the
way i'm gonna teach these three boys
what being a father and a husband
actually looks like
and you're they're gonna get a ringside
seat to ownership and responsibility and
working your butt off and achieving a
goal is that fair
yeah okay so the two two options you got
are to sell this thing and hopefully
cross all of your fingers
and
and and toes that you get out bear even
right and then you go rent a house and
you're not gonna it's not gonna change
your financial position month to month
but it's gonna get that
rock off that you know that rock
necklace off your neck underwater right
so that's number one or
um you decide we're gonna buckle down
and we're gonna keep this house and
you're gonna have to go make 25 000 more
dollars before the end of this month
whether that's you're driving you're
getting up in the morning you're mowing
lawns on the weekends whatever it looks
like
and it's going to rip your soul out
because you're going to want to spend
all the waking moments you have with
those three little boys and you're not
going to be able to okay but you're
going to go
the map is 25 000 dollars more
hey i just made that number up i'm just
telling you you're gonna have to double
if go 50 up double your income you need
a lot more money every month and your
wife's gonna have to get a job too do
you guys have any debt okay
other than the house house just a house
do you have any money in savings
i got about
2500 i think
okay
kind of a starter emergency fund we're
gonna have to beef that up if we're
gonna continue to be homeowners because
just one hvac going out is going to tank
you guys and cause you to go further
into debt if i'm george yeah george and
isaac if i'm you isaac i'm gonna sell
this house yeah i'm gonna sell the house
i'm gonna rent something i might even go
get radical and get a two-bedroom
apartment
and me and my wife are gonna agree to
lock arms in this for six to nine months
that means we're gonna have evenings
um one of us is going to take them to
the park while the other one's working
or whatever get them out of the house
obviously or they're gonna they're gonna
burn it to the ground but we're going to
go all in and get a huge
emergency fund
we're going to get a
nice down payment and then we're going
to be able to exhale and it's going to
take about a year of just grinding it
out and then you're going to flip you're
going to flip the script here and you're
going to be in a good position and one
of the most beautiful parts about
renting is that you are transferring
risk back to the landlord so if
something goes wrong
and that's part of the stress you're
feeling is if one thing goes wrong in
this plan we're screwed so i want to
help you guys out home warranty and it
sucked
covers nothing yeah so isaac i'm going
to give to you financial peace
university i want you and your wife to
watch every single one of those nine
lessons in there along with that i'm
gonna give you our premium version of
our budgeting tool every dollar i want
you and your wife to sit down together
write down your income all of your
expenses map it out see where we can
shave so that we can get by for now as
we increase income so hang on the line
austin's going to pick up we're going to
gift you the both of those things please
use them we're cheering for you man call
us back
hey i'm going to throw this on too i'm
going to give you ken coleman's paycheck
to purpose because you're going to get a
new job you're probably going to go to
community college or go to night school
and you're going to get a degree and
you're going to get a job and i'm also
going to send you my book
own your past change your future you're
going to set this shame down and you're
going to get to making things happen
what aren't we sending him you
you stay with me i'll stay here john for
safety